hey guys I want to answer this one
question that a person had relating to
being on keto okay and then once you
fully adapt and you're actually in fat
burning and you plateau in another video
I mentioned you on the lower your
dietary fat to force your body to burn
its own fat okay and so the follow-up
question that this person had was this
if I cut back on fat won't my calories
be too low okay so that's the question
and we're going we're gonna answer take
a look at this you you were burning
sugar now you want a keto you're doing
it a minute fasting and now you have
been converted to fat okay so you're
burning fat and it's been maybe one to
two months and you you've adapted so
your hunger scone and your cravings are
down and everything is smooth but let's
say your metabolism is a little bit slow
and things are sluggish and you're just
not you're not losing as much as you'd
like
so if you start to lower your dietary
fat down to about 75 grams maybe a
little bit less this forces your own
body to use your own stored fat now
think about it an average skinny person
has about between eighty to a hundred
thousand store calories of fat on their
body so that's a lot of fat to run off
of so when you're doing keto and in a
minute fasting you're dropping your
carbs and you're forcing your body to
burn fat which is a very good thing
that's a natural thing but if you're
doing in a minute fasting at one meal or
two meals per day then you reduce your
fat what does that leave you with three
to six ounces of protein and vegetables
is this gonna be enough well hopefully
you're doing larger quantities of
vegetables here's the missing piece of
the puzzle yes these are small amount of
calories the main thing is to get your
nutrients God is the key so you want to
go high quality with this 75 grams like
some salmon while caught beef things
like that and maybe some fish oil and
then high quality vegetables so you get
your nutrients so yes three to six
ounces of protein and a big salad if
you're doing one meal a day is
not gonna add up to that many calories
let's say it's 900 calories but realize
that a good portion of the calories that
you're burning and the energy that
you're getting is from your body fat
calories okay so the calories are not
just 900 it's more and this is why you
can go from meal to meal without being
hungry too much okay because your body
is being fed it's just not being fed by
the diet it's being fed by the stored
fat so if you plateaued and you're at
one the two meals a day probably one mil
a day and you cut back on your fat don't
really worry about the calories worry
about the nutrients focus on increasing
the nutrients nutrient-dense foods and
realize that you're not going to starve
because your body's burning up its own
stored fat okay and those definitely
count as the total calories that you're
burning so just don't omit the body fat
thanks for watching if you're liking
this content please subscribe now and I
will actually keep you updated on future
videos